when the EU granted a brexit extension
in April Donald Tusk pleaded with MPs
don't waste this time well since then
cross party talks have collapsed there
seems little realistic prospect of the
brexit deal passing and the Conservative
Party has now embarked on a potentially
lengthy leadership contest well joining
us now is the defense minister Tobias
Elwood thank you very much for being on
the program this morning
now I'm keen to get to the the drama in
the Conservative Party in a few moments
but I'm also want to start on an issue
that is very serious I know you've been
looking at it closely and on mental
health awareness week just how much of
an issue is mental health for our armed
forces this is such an important issue
I'm really pleased that we're starting
with this mental health awareness week
has just taken place last week we don't
really speak enough about it and yet a
third of the nation will be affected by
it in one way or another and in the
armed forces where it's a very matter
atmosphere there of course people are
reluctant to speak about it and we've
done our best to change the strategy so
you speak about mental health on parity
with physical health people in the armed
forces are happy to say I've got a knee
injury but Leslie less willing to say
there's something wrong with my mind
indeed when I served very much so you
were laughed at or you certainly told to
keep it to yourself which is the worst
thing because then it incubate so now
we're getting people to talk about it
we're making them more resilient so
they're aware of what happens when they
move to theatres of operations we have
compression periods afterwards as well
but from a peer-to-peer perspective
getting people to spot it letting them
know that if they step forward and say
can I saw myself out it won't affect
their career has the government done
enough previously to try and support
people in the armed forces in this way
well I think as I say there's been a
huge change in it but it has been
cultural there's been this stigma
attached to talking about the issue so
the concern I have is less with Iraq and
Afghan veterans it's actually those
perhaps to do the Falklands War who
departed the Armed Forces unaware of
what helped is available and that's so
important to understand because we have
excellent support now for those serving
the armed forces but we've also improved
the support that's available for our
veterans as well they need to know where
to go
to receive that help
I'm keen to talk to you about another
military story in the newspapers this
morning the Sunday Telegraph is claiming
that the Prime Minister blocked
legislation that could have protected
veterans from prosecution I mean this is
particularly relevant of course in
relation to Northern Ireland
Johnny master your colleague says this
is a betrayal is it we need to place it
in perspective first of all I served in
Northern Ireland I'm very conscious that
in as we move in through a
reconciliation process that we're able
to get to the bottom warts been perhaps
not the best process in looking back at
some of those outstanding issues that
needed to be closed down that were part
of that
Stallman process unfortunately it's not
been done in the best way the Northern
Ireland sector is aware of that she's
organised a consultation to see how it
can be improved but if you want to as
number 10 I think has responded to the
story to say that you can't give an
amnesty just Armed Forces personnel
you'd have to share that with terrorists
as well and she was unwilling to do that
that's international law that's what we
have to abide by so Johnny Mercer is
wrong on this then you think well I
don't know exactly what he said I'm not
I spoke to him many times on that I know
he's absolutely passionate as all of us
are to say to look after our own forces
and make it very very clear that anybody
who is involved in any of these
inquiries they will receive mmod support
legal advice straight away could I just
take the opportunity because we won't
say - nothing this country to say thank
you to anybody that has served or is
serving maybe we're a bit reserved in
this country we compared the madness
state system like that but it's
something that I think the country is
very very proud of but perhaps you don't
share enough to say thank you to those
who put a uniform on okay now let's move
on to brexit shall we have a little look
at the latest poll for the European
elections should be appearing just a few
moments the Greens of leapfrog - in this
poll for you got I mean why I think it's
going so wrong well firstly it's a vote
which we weren't expecting to have so
many people won't even participate in
that 2014 the vote took place for
European
I think the turnout was about 32% so
this is not a second referendum it is a
an opportunity to express your anger
your frustration at this government we
promised to deliver brexit and we're
still found wanting and that's why you
see these numbers here as well and that
is actually understood what we also need
to recognize the fact that we need to
get a deal we need to actually move
forward with this and that's why the
Prime Minister will come back in June
first week of June and present the
withdrawal agreement bill itself which
is phase 1 let's make it clear it's how
you depart it's the agreement of the
divorce if you like I'm the difficulty
is I mean the easy bit for the
government to rally around is that you
want to see a deal the difficult but is
what happens if that deal as expected
doesn't pass Parliament when I spoke to
the Bret's that secretary will have a
look and the interview a little later on
the program and he said that if the
withdrawal agreement fails then
preparations for No Deal
need to be sped up a pace as he put it
that's right he has to say that because
that is the legal background in which we
face we end up at the 31st of October if
there's nothing on the table and we
don't get a further extension or support
from the EU then that's the legal
default that we go to and it's obviously
correct that we actually have
contingency preparations for that but I
make it very clear that no deal is not a
destination
no deal is not where you want to end up
it's the way you accidentally go if we
don't actually have that we deal it do
you prefer to see no brexit rather than
no deal I don't even want to entertain
those questions I think there I'm
helpful we need to focus these are the
questions you obtain because you know
this is gonna be the fourth time that
the deal is put to Parliament that the
talks of collapse between labor I mean
these are the difficult questions we
need to ask well let's see what happens
next week because you're looking back we
now know the Prime Minister will speak
more of her the bold initiatives that
she's putting forward and an opportunity
in June but I stress again of what no
deal actually means no deal is and
firstly I understand the frustration of
Britain saying you know why is it you've
not landed it No Deal is clinical it's
clean let's just do it let's get away
I'm frustrated with the EU but look at
the detail that's what I invite people
to do a bit
divorce you can run out the building if
you like and say I want to you know
leave my my other half but actually
there's more to it than that you know
where's the money gonna go who's going
to get the house the cat if you've got
children you've got a responsibility an
ongoing relationship to discuss and
that's exactly what we have with the
European Union as well so defaulting to
WTO terms as wife it make the case for
that - that isn't Premier League if you
want to do a football analogy that's
liking us and your camera crew going
outside into the grass and using our
football bags you know as the gold pace
it is the most basic of trade
relationships and we are the fifth
largest trading nation in the world we
can do better than that that's not where
we want to be it would be damaging to
our economy because of what it would do
to trade particularly agriculture
aerospace and so forth it would damage
our security because we would lose the
threat picture across Europe and also
reputationally I was in Italy a few days
ago for the anniversary of the center
fifth anniversary of the Battle of Monte
Cassino and there of course people were
asking about brexit saying why is the
paralysis not where do you want to go
but why is it actually taking so long
internationally to go to No Deal would
damage our reputation as a country that
is involved that participates on the
international stage it were you a
retrograde step okay
now the leadership contest is in full
swing are you gonna run am I going to
run straight question answer and I'll
give you a straight answer I didn't have
the rank and I don't have the experience
I'm not going to run and this isn't a TV
reality contest your introduction just
prompted me to think how does it look to
the nation when we've just spoken on the
biggest issue brexit and take brexit if
this was brexit or the the decision of
brexit and you remove it from the table
you actually have a nation where the
economy is going well better than Japan
better than Germany from climate change
best in the g20 inflation targets under
control employment doing really well all
of that is brilliant
put brexit back on the table and it all
disappears what we are doing to Britain
our reputation is actually being
affected by brexit look at the polls not
from here but the results are eventually
the leadership
absolutely matters when it comes to
brexit because who is the next leader of
the Conservative Party is going to take
the UK potentially in very different
directions I know it's a brexit so who
would you like to see as the next leader
let's do let's have some loyalty let's
have some commitment let's have some
discipline in focusing on the one thing
putting in my class here the one thing
that we need to get across line which is
brexit the idea that we jump ahead and
start toying around which we you know
who should be the leader and then
everybody know you talk about the grand
national I mean I do urge my colleagues
to think why are they putting their name
forward is it to raise their own profile
and some a there are some colleagues as
well as changing their views in order to
woo our membership to raise their
profile as well this is getting things
in the wrong order a focus must be to
get brexit across the line get that out
the way so we could then have a bigger
wider debate as to how we should earn
the respect of the nation to be a one
nation Progressive Party center-right
fiscally responsible able to take the
nation forward and most importantly
engage with a younger generation which
were failing to do you sound quite
frustrated I am too frustrated I really
am because this entire process you know
we are one of the oldest political party
in the world our popularity herbs and
flows it's important that we show that
discipline focuses our mind on what
needs to be done and then have that
important debate with our party but the
debate at moment is actually been
focused the wrong way around we're
trying to actually impress our
membership and then ask our membership
what they want and then repeat those
rather than looking beyond a mere
membership beyond our base so what
excites the nation to say what is it
that can allow the Conservative Party to
continue to be in office okay thank you
very much for being on the program today
okay